no I'm not lying to my child and making
up a story you're going to ruin their
childhood it's here's what it will be
fomo for life Santa is a make belief
story that we play pretend is happening
it's not real it's just we're going to
have play pretend I think it's cool it's
magical it's not for me if your kid
tells people that's where the problem is
I'm not going to encourage that I'm just
going to say look so you're going to
make her be a liar no I'm going to say
look are you going to or is she going to
lie because you're ruining people's
Christmas if some of your friends are
stupid enough to believe that Santa is
real let's just let them be